Das Bock hast Ufo. Das Bock hast Ufo. Wurdest du schon mal süss genannt und du hast gedacht, das ist kein Kompliment. Ja, das ist ja auch so ein bisschen dieses Mann-Frau-Ding. Männer wollen nicht süss genannt werden, Frauen wollen süss genannt werden. Wirklich? Männer wollen cool sein oder schön. Frauen wollen süss genannt werden? Ja, oder nicht? Ist das nicht das Geschicht? Ich habe keine Ahnung. Sag ich mir so, während ich aus einer runden Tasse trinke, meinen kleinen Finger abspreize und genüsslich Kaffee schlürfe. Stefan, wenn ich wüsste, was Frauen hören wollen, säße ich heute nicht mit dir hier in deinem Hotelzimmer in Hamburg. Herzlich willkommen übrigens zum Hotel-Ufo. Schön, dass ihr da seid. Hallo auch von mir. Wir sind heute in Hamburg. Ich habe Florian in meine große Suite Grand Suite eingeladen. Und ja, heute nehmen wir mal hier eine Folge On the Road auf, eine alte Hotelfolge. Die Podcaster Suite hat er sich ausgesucht, da hängen auch ganz viele ICE-Fahrpläne dran und ganz viele Studiosachen sind hier. Ganz fantastische erste Folge im Jahre 2020, herzlichen Glückwunsch. Schön, dass du da bist. Sag's nicht, sag's nicht. Ich sag's nicht? Sag nicht die verbotenen Wörter. Nein, wie gesagt, ab 6. Januar muss man nicht mehr frohes neues Jahr wünschen für alle da draußen, die Orientierung suchen, ah, man trifft den Chef, oh nein, jetzt die war im Urlaub, kommt zurück und dann sagt man jetzt noch frohes neues Jahr, 6. Januar ist der Stichtag, das ist auch glaube ich Heilige Drei Könige.
Da ist Heiliger Könige und da muss man auch sagen, ist dann einfach auch vorbei. Das mag für viele zu früh erscheinen, tut uns leid, dass wir da an der Stelle vielleicht ein bisschen zu früh dieses Datum gesetzt haben, das war ein schnelles Brainstorming, wurde abrupt abgebrochen auch, weil dann auch irgendwann Mittag bestellt werden musste. Von Balthasar, muss man auch sagen, der Ungeduldige der drei. Das Erste, was ich in Wien gesehen habe, war ein geblackfaceder Junge. Ich war Heiliger König, kam ich in Wien an, habe vor einer Woche schön zum Entspannen meinen Jahresurlaub direkt rausgehauen. Ja. Und das was ich gesehen habe, waren Blackface der Junge, der als Melchior oder Kaspar oder Balthasar. Also, ich dachte, der ist völlig unabhängig von drei Könige. Das nicht, nee, der war einer der dunklenhäutigen drei Könige. Das ist Balthasar, glaube ich. Oder Melchior oder Kaspar. Ehrlich gesagt, ich bin eher für die anderen beiden. Ich würde gerne 50-50-Joker nehmen. Ich war über Weihnachtstage bei meinen Eltern und meine Mutter ist ja Autorin auch und die schreibt Bücher. Wirklich jetzt? Die hat ein Buch geschrieben, so eine Art Adventskalenderbuch mit 24 kleinen Geschichten über ein Engelchen, das aus dem Himmel fällt auf die Erde und dann dort vierundzwanzig kleine Abenteuer erlitten.
Wie süss! Wie süss! Kann man das jetzt sagen? Ja. Was man dazu sagen muss, meine Mutter ist begeisterte Fotobearbeiterin am Computer und sie macht alle Fotos, die sie schiesst. Macht sie es gerne und gut? Sie macht die Fotos gerne sehr fetzig, sagen wir mal, und oft zur Unkenntlichkeit überfiltert.
Ich kenne das Problem, man fielen so viele Tönefilter.
Und vor allem ist es so, wenn du so ein Bildbearbeitungsprogramm programmierst, dann machst du ja so eine gewisse Range Filterkontrast und baust so naja 10%, 20 gucken. Bei meiner Mutter auf Anschlag, wirklich direkt jeden Regler genommen und auf Anschlag direkt. Kontrast, Schatten und dann ist auch schon das Spektakulum fertig. Genau, wo der Programmierer sich ein Spektrum denkt, denkt meine Mutter binär, Filter an, Filter aus, Maximum. Und dann gab es eben auch eine Geschichte zu den Sternsingern. Das kleine Engelchen ist dann unterwegs und die Sternsinger und das versteht sie nicht und so. Und dann hat meine Mutter ein Bild gebraucht für die Sternsinger in dem Buch und hat aber keins gefunden.
Und dann hat sie lange gesucht und hat keines gefunden, was sie verwenden kann und hat dann ein altes Foto aus der Schulzeit einer ihrer Kinder, ich habe ja zwei Brüder, aus der Schulzeit gefunden, wo ich glaube einer meiner Brüder beim Krippenspiel ein Hirten gespielt hat und da war so ein Foto von einigen Kindern in den Hirtenkostümen. Und dann dachte meine Mutter, das ist ja perfekt, die sehen ja so ein bisschen aus mit den langen Mänteln, so ein bisschen wie Könige. Jetzt waren die aber natürlich... Kurse Kritik aber auch mal an der Kostümabteilung, wenn Hirten so aussehen, ein bisschen so aussehen wie Könige, grosses Fragezeichen. Wobei man sich fragen kann, was ist schlimmer, wenn die Hirten aussehen wie Könige oder wenn die Könige aussehen wie Hirten? Also wo würdest du eher aufstehen und sagen, dafür habe ich nicht 1,50 Euro an der Kasse für den Schulausflug gezahlt? Jetzt hat sie dieses Bild mit den Hirten gefunden, aber da war natürlich keiner schwarz. Oh mein Gott! Gottoste, dann gibt es einen Regler dafür, auch bei Photoshop, oder nicht? Und natürlich muss bei den Heiligen drei Königen... Oder ist jetzt zum Perzen zum Pinselwerkzeug gegriffen? Natürlich muss bei den Heiligen drei Königen ja einer. Der Kasper muss ja der Schwarze sein. Und dann hat meine Mutter gedacht, ja, wie mache ich das denn jetzt? Da muss ich wohl in die Nachbararbeitung. Oh mein Gott, oh nein. Und du greifst zum Handy, zu einem neuen Handy, muss man sagen, auf das ich mich schon sehr freue. Und meine Mutter hat mir das erzählt und ich dachte nur, ach du meine Güte, was kommt da jetzt auf mich zu? Du hast das Bild auf deinem Handy. Ich habe das Bild auf meinem Handy und ich zeige dir jetzt das Bild, das meine Mutter bearbeitet hat. Eine ältere weisse Frau. Wie sie aus einer Gruppe weisser Kinder die Heiligen drei Könige gemacht hat. Holy fuck. Ohohoho! Das gibt es nicht. Das darfst du niemals. Ich wollte gerade sagen, cool, kannst du direkt Twitter hochladen, bei Twitter oder so. Auf gar keinen Fall darf das jemals jemand sehen, sonst ist der Verfassungsschutz nicht nur in dem Elternhaus zugegen, sondern auch bei uns. Das ist ja unglaublich. Darf ich kurz beschreiben, was sie gemacht hat? Sie hat so eine Art Filter angewendet, der so ein bisschen die Konturen verfremdet, ein bisschen einfacher macht, so eine Art Zeichenstil. Weshalb so Silhouetten zu erkennen sind eher und so und grössere Farbgruppen, also so grössere Farbklecks, nicht die einzelnen feinen Konturen und hat einen einfach ganz schwarz gemacht. Das ist einfach wie ein schwarzer Geist. Es ist weniger schlimm, als ich dachte. Ich dachte, es wird wirklich so digitales Blackfacing. Der gesamte Inhalt des Kopfes ist einfach pechschwarz. Alles, pechschwarz. Es sieht aus wie einer der Nazgul. Ja, es sieht aus wie Nazgul. Und ich musste mich wirklich kurz hinlegen, als ich dieses Bild gesehen habe, weil es so fantastisch ist.
Und ja, das war mein Feier.
Das gibt es nicht. Und wo man einfach so merkt, es sind so verschiedene gefährliche Dinge, die zusammenkommen, so Mutter mit zweifelhaften Photoshop-Skills und dann aus einer ganz anderen Richtung der gesellschaftlichen Probleme Blackfacing. Und die nähern sich so, man denkt sich wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow wow eine Sekunde stopp stopp stopp. Wie diese Spiele, was man damals im Sportunterricht mal gespielt hat, wenn es kurz vor den Ferien war, dieses man guckt sich um und Leute kommen näher und dann muss man weggucken und dann muss man hingucken und dann bleiben sie stehen und dürfen sich nicht bewegen. Wie hieß dieses Spiel nochmal? Weiß ich nicht. Wer hat Angst vor dem Schwarzen Waden? Ah ja, richtig! Auch hier wieder. Auch hier wieder, aber man muss sich doch umdrehen und gucken, und dann müssen die Klassenkameraden, sie dürfen sich nicht mehr bewegen. Ja, genau. Dann muss man wieder Augen zumachen, dann können sie wieder näher kommen. Und das ist so ein bisschen so, wie bei diesen Sachen, es kommen so Probleme auf einen zu, aber wenn man hinguckt, dann passiert nichts. Und dann ist man kurz, ich habe das Gefühl, man ist ja für Eltern und auch so in gewisser Weise ein bisschen so ein Korrektiv. Weil du ja bist ja gerade als junger Mann oder als junge Frau bist du dann auch eher so ein bisschen gerade, kriegst du die Strömung in der Gesellschaft mit und so. Und es ist ja normal, dass ältere Semester halt vielleicht nicht so sehr da am Puls der Zeit sind. Aber toll, dass sie zwar auch lustig ist, aus diesem Wunsch da heraus, Diversity auch zu erzeugen. Etwas ganz anderes. Ich weiß nicht, ob es Diversity ist. Es ist ja einfach gegeben mit den Heiligen drei Königen. Aber die kriegen Props von ihr. Genau, die kriegen Props, ja. Gut, Frau wäre auch nicht schlecht, aber da ist jetzt mal... Und Jesus war weiss. Der weisseste in allen Abbildungen war Jesus, der weisseste Mensch der Welt. Aber es waren wirklich so zwei Problemherde, die sich annähern. Wenn du so ein Video siehst und du siehst ein Video und denkst dir, oh, cool, eine Schlange. Boa Constrictor, interessante Tiere. Oh, da ist eine kleine Maus jetzt zu sehen. Oh nein. Oh, die sind die Leben zusammen, oder was fressen Schlangenlangen. Oh, oh, oh Gott, oh Gott, oh shit. Und genauso war das auch, und es war, es war fantastisch. Und ja, es ist ein, es ist ein.
Auch noch mal ein kleiner Nachtrag zu meinen Weihnachten. Vielen Dank für die zahlreichen Nachrichten bezüglich meines Laptops, des Laptops meiner Mutter. Oh Gott, ey, wie da die Kommentarspalte zugestopft wurde. Und dann vor allem, als ich das Wort Linux gelesen habe, dachte ich mir, okay, fuck it, ich höre hier auf. Das war auch der Punkt, wo ich alle Nachrichten blockiert habe, mit so gewissen, mit den Wörtern Laptop da drin, weil, zumalteile ich, der beste Vorschlag fand ich, ja, wir hatten das, es fing super an, die Nachricht, die fing wirklich konstruktiv an, wir hatten exakt das gleiche Problem auch mit dem Laptop unserer Mutter über Weihnachten, auch ein Dell-Laptop, wow, auch ein Telekom-Router und dann habe ich da überflogen und dachte mir, ja, ja, ja, dann haben wir den Router einfach weggeworfen. Und das war dann die Lösung, wo ich auch dachte, gut, jetzt wird es aber auch ein bisschen unkonstruktiv.
Oder wiederum konstruktiv und das ist wirklich die Lösung. Weiß ich nicht. Vielen Dank für die Nachrichten.
Ich war noch nicht wieder zu Hause und konnte mir das Problem nicht nochmal annähern, aber wir kriegen das hin. Gemeinsam kriegen wir das hin. Problem ist noch nicht gelöst, nehme ich an. Es bleibt weiter bestehen. Es bleibt weiter spannend, auf jeden Fall, ja. Ja, es ist hartnäckig. Genau, wir sind heute im Hotelzimmer und das ist ja auch vielleicht auch eine gute Möglichkeit, um über Hotelzimmer an sich zu sprechen. Haben wir ja interessanterweise beim letzten Mal schon gemacht, weil ich da im Hotel war, diesmal warst du im Hotel. Ja, wir sind beide im Hotel. Es ist, also hier sind wirklich fantastische Dinge, gehen hier vor sich. Was ich spannend finde, das ist mittlerweile gang und gäbe, dass man kostenlos Wasser bekommt. Stand da drüben, da drüben, droben, wo du siehst, da war Flaschenwasser und diese zwei Glä Gläser dazu. Dann war ich jetzt hier vier Nächte. Am ersten Tag wurde noch eine hingestellt wieder, ich habe jeweils beide getrunken, eine wurde hingestellt wieder, am dritten Tag wurde keine mehr hingestellt. Das heißt, man entscheidet sich langsam dagegen, also man guckt auch als Hotelpersonal, guckt man auch ein bisschen, wie weit man das Spiel treiben kann, weil die wollen ja auch nicht alles umsonst mitgeben. Ja, ich verstehe schon. Das ist auch ein bisschen interessant. Und dann habe ich ganz gewiebt, in der Minibar sind nämlich die gleichen Flaschen Wasser, habe ich ausgetauscht. Nämlich, ich habe das einfach von da genommen, das kostenlose und in den Kühlschrank gemacht und da das kalte rausgenommen. Das ist ja noch okay, aber dann wollte ich gerne lieber das Wasser mit Kohlensäure haben. Also habe ich ein stilles Wasser, was es kostenlos gibt, reingenommen und das andere, jetzt sind hier in der Minibar zwei stille Wasser. Ich muss dich hier leider verhaften, es tut mir leid, Sie haben das Recht auf einen Anwalt, Sie haben das Recht, früher auszuchatten. Das ist das Krasseste, was ich jemals gemacht habe. Also es geht darüber hinaus, bin ich glaube ich sehr korrekt, aber das habe ich jetzt mal gemacht. Jetzt sind ja hier in der Minibar zwei stille Wasser. Ja, wir haben auch ein Hotel untergebracht während der Dreharbeiten für die unwahrscheinlichen Ereignisse im Leben von, kennt niemand. Und da haben wir uns dann auch immer morgens getroffen im Hotel und dann einer, der Ryan war das aus dem Ensemble, erzählt dann so, ich wollte mir gestern Abend noch so ein Bier aus der Minibar nehmen und dann mache ich das Bier auf, denke mir, ah cool, entspanntes Feierabendbier, irgendwie stressiger Drehtag und so, setze das Bier an, das Wasser. Bitte was? Das Wasser. Aber Moment mal, Wasser in der Bierflasche oder? Wasser in der Bierflasche. Und dann stellt sich raus, dass es anscheinend Leute gibt, die aus der Minibar die Getränke trinken und einfach durch Wasser ersetzen, damit die eingebaute Waage in der Minibar nicht anspringt und Alarm schlägt. Nein, damit das eingebaute Hotelpersonal nicht vorm Auschecken bemerkt, dass das Bier geöffnet ist. Aber das Hotelpersonal probiert doch einmal jedes Getränk durch, oder? Also hätte ich jetzt gedacht. Ja, aber erst ab vier Sterne plus. Aber da kam er morgens an und war wirklich enttäuscht. Er hat 16 Euro für ein Bierchen ausgegeben und dann war es nur Wasser. Ja, und nuckelt an einer Flasche, die schon ein anderer im Mund hatte. Das ist auch bescheuert. Aber da würde ich dich jetzt als Grenzfall bezeichnen, weil das ist jetzt auch so, da mache ich mir eine schöne Kohlensäure auf und dann setze ich an und Wasser, stilles Wasser. Ich habe ja nicht angefangen, rumzuseppermitieren, mit meinem Kosmos-Chemie-Baukasten hier Dinge umgefüllt, das habe ich ja nicht. Ich habe nur ausgetauscht. Ich habe nur ein Bier braun, das ist doch, wenn du da ein bisschen Hopfen reintust und das stehen lässt. Stehen lässt. Ist doch kein Problem. Ist doch kein Problem. Es darf ja nicht der Erste trinken, der ist hochgiftig, er muss halt ein bisschen stehen noch. Zu Weihnachten hat auch mein Vater ein Bierbrauset geschenkt bekommen. Ah ja. Das heißt, es kann jetzt wahrscheinlich bald Willbier geben. Willbier. Willbier und natürlich die Wortwitzel Through the Roof. Ja, prasseln, jetzt schon brauchen wir ein. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, was daraus wird oder ob am Ende alles explodiert einfach. Bielbier, ja vielleicht stösst du ja auf so eine irre Art, Bier zu machen. Aber ich glaube, da ist man mittlerweile schon gut durch. Ich glaube, Bier ist durchgespielt, glaube ich. Indian Pale Ale ist ja auch nur entstanden, weil die Engländer auf der großen Reise nach Indien oder umgekehrt Bier verschiffen wollten, was haltbar ist, solange den ganzen Seeweg durchhält. Und deswegen haben die ein sehr haltbares Bier kreiert und dadurch ist dann in den Pale Ale entstanden. Das sind so kleine Funfacts. Das heißt, die Bier ist ja auch schon so alt, da hat man mittlerweile alles durch. Ja, Bier ist durchgespielt. Und deswegen finde ich es auch immer ein bisschen unfair, wenn Leute dann so sagen, so diese veganen Alternativen, so, ne, du hast jetzt Käse und dann hast du den veganen Käse und oh, der schmeckt ja gar nicht so gut. Wo ich mir denke, ja, Käse wird von der Menschheit halt auch schon seit viertausend Jahren gemacht. Also Erfahrungsschatz veganer Käse zwei Jahre, Erfahrungsschatz echter Käse viertausend Jahre. Wobei es gab vielleicht auch Zeiten dazwischen, wo man das Käsewissen nicht unbedingt perfekt weitergegeben hat. Meinst du, da ist Käsewissen untergegangen? Ich glaube auch. Da haben die Türken angegriffen und alle so, rette die Käserezepte schnell! Ja, ich glaube auch, man sagt ja hier, das wäre auch, jetzt ist ja die große Diskussion, ist Tesla, baut Tesla auch gute Autos oder so, können die ja gar nicht, die haben ja gar nicht die Erfahrung, die zum Beispiel deutsche Marken wie Mercedes oder VW haben und so. Und allein die Spaltmasse, man schaue sich die Spaltmasse an und so weiter. Schrecklich. Aber ich denke mir auch, ist es wirklich so, dass man nur weil die Firma älter ist, gleichzeitig auch die besseren Archive hatte? Es kommt ja auf die, wie gut, die Firma ist nur so gut wie die Archivare waren, weil das wissen wir dann nicht immer perfekt weitergegeben. Kommen ja auch Leute dazu, gehen Leute weg. Ja, ich weiss auch nicht. Waren die Übergaben jeweils gut? Ich glaube, es ist schon wichtig, mal einen so im Team zu haben, wo dann, wenn dann die jungen Wilden sagen, so, aber vier Räder, lass doch mal out of the box denken, warum denn nicht fünf? Und dann sich so der alte Mann aus der letzten Reihe, das haben wir damals in den 60ernern schon versucht und er ist gestorben und dann stirbt er was habt ihr versucht und dann macht man wieder fünf Räder und dann ach scheiße und dann muss man die ganzen Lektionen wieder neu lernen hast du von dem Praktikanten mitbekommen der jetzt bei der NASA den den Planeten entdeckt hat was ein Bullshit ich bin so sauer auch über Meldung die ganze Zeit gewesen, weil als ob der dann da mathematische Gleichungen aufgestellt hat und den Himmel abgesucht hat, gezielt und den gefunden hat. Nein, jeder kennt doch von sich ein Praktikum. Da bist du ja hingesetzt, darfst du dann mal mit auf die Maus klicken und so, bist dann eh schon an dem Stern, den dieser Professor eh schon die ganze Zeit beobachtet, so, und dann kriegt er die ganzen Credits jetzt dafür, nicht der Professor, der die ganze Zeit schon an diesem Himmel aktiv gefunden hat, weil er irgendwie Sachen hinziehen und etwas auf Gravitation hindeutet und dann diesen Stern beobachtet, und jetzt kriegt der scheiß Praktikant da, weil er da hingesetzt wurde und die Credits. Um Planeten zu finden, ist keine Leistung in meinen Augen. Das ist ja nicht so, wie wenn du jetzt irgendwie den Mörder suchst oder so, du musst dann Clues zusammennehmen und dann, ah, deduktiv denken und so. Du guckst einfach in den leeren Sternenhimmel oder halt in die Daten von deren krassen Spektroskopen, was auch immer. Und dann sagst du, ah, hier, zack. Ja, cool. Lächerlich. Das möchte ich mal, dass du das Anna-Frebel ins Gesicht sagst. Ja, da werde ich die mal schön zurückfrebeln, wenn die das nächste Mal kommen, werde ich sagen, so schwer ist das nicht, so schwer ist das nicht. Ich erinnere an die Folge, wo du noch sehr, oh, ist ja alles ganz toll, was die machen. Ja, weil wir uns davor zweimal verfrebelt haben. Super aufgeregt war es, weil wir uns verfrebelt haben, natürlich auch, aber dann jetzt dann so, jetzt sich zurückzufrebeln, hier hinterrücks zurückzufrebeln, finde ich auch gemein. Ja, irgendwann hat man, das ist genauso wie die erste Spinne, die gefunden wurde, wow, krass, die zweite, wow, krass und mittlerweile so, ah, ich habe die 14.622 Spinne gefunden, wir benennen sie nach Will Smith, haha, und alle so, mir ist scheiss egal, das interessiert niemand. Hat sie mehr als, hat sie zwölf Beine? Nein, dann egal. Dann egal. Dann ist auch wirklich egal. Arachnophoben. Ne, Arachnoiden. Gibt's arachnophobe Spinnen eigentlich? Gibt's das schweres, schweres Los, das man gezogen hat eigentlich. Ja, wobei es gibt, das ist nicht das gleiche wie Leute, die vor Menschen, die vor Menschen Angst haben. Gibt's Anthropophobie, dass man Angst hat vor Menschen? Ich glaube, ich gehöre dazu. Aber du hast keine Angst vor Menschen. Ich habe Angst vor vielen Menschen. Aber doch nicht nicht vor allen Menschen. Naja, aber wenn du eine Phobie hast, dann sagst du nicht, ja, ich habe nur vor denen mit einer blutigen Axt in der Hand Angst. Doch, ich habe vor Menschen mit... Und der Therapeut sagt, ich glaube, wir haben es, oder? Ich habe vor Menschen mit Hockeymasken Angst. Blutigen Hockeymasken. Ich weiß nicht, es gibt wahrscheinlich alles als Phobie, aber Phobie vor Menschen ist schon ein Problem. Weil dann, wie will man das therapieren? Wie spezifisch muss eine Angst sein, damit es nicht mehr einen Namen hat oder nicht mehr diagnostizierbar ist? Die Angst vor Menschen, die mir so nahe kommen mit spitzen Gegenständen, ist ja keine Phobie, sondern gesunde Angst. Ja gut, ja, das stimmt schon. Angst vor wilden Tieren, ich auch, achtenrach eine Phobie macht ja auch Sinn. Es ist ja auch gut, dass Menschen erstmal in der Höhle damals ein paar Stunden zurückgegangen sind bei Spinnen. Sie haben tendenziell ja keinen schlechter Impuls. Ich bin auch Säbelzahntiger-Phob. Wobei ich glaube, eine Phobie ist schon anders definiert, dass es irgendwie in anderen Aspekten das Leben einschränken muss, als es nur, ich habe Angst vor giftigen Spinnen. Ist Homophobie da nicht streng genommen die Angst vor Schwulenulen das ja ist es schon aber das ist ja so das ding dass es eigentlich ein unglücklicher name ist eigentlich unglücklich ja das kann man so sagen vieles wieder unnicht gelaufen aber again big story ja haben wir auch da haben wir das war der gleiche abend wo wir den sechsten januar als letzten tag festgelegt haben an dem man ein frohes neues sagen kann ich habe vielehes Neues beobachtet dieses Jahr. In so Läden,
in denen ich gegangen bin, haben sich dann so Kassierer gesehen zum ersten Mal, aber es war schon weit nach dem sechsten. Da bin ich dann auch kopfschüttelnd und auch schweigend, aber kopfschüttelnd umhergelaufen und habe gesagt, das kann nicht sein. War eigentlich zur Zeit von Jesus und Jesus' Geburt auch schon Da Jahreswechsel? Also waren die auf der, waren die dann so, ah, also zwischen Weihnachten und Heilige Drei Könige war ja Silvester dann. Das heisst, die Heiligen Drei Könige haben ja unterwegs Silvester gefeiert dann eigentlich, das ist ein Teil der Reise. Ohne Scheiss, zu dritt dann auch, man kennt sich nicht gut. Man hat ein Tischfeuerwerk dabei. Man hat auch nur ein Thema, also irgendwie König sein, so viel verbindet die ja auch nicht.
Wobei, das ist schon gut auch.
Vor allem, wer hat unter drei Königen die Krone auf, ist halt die Frage so.
Wer ist da der Anführer?
Und dem bricht man vielleicht einen Zacken aus der Krone.
Das stimmt. Und wie weiß man eigentlich, wann genau null Uhr ist?
Ja, und sprechen die eigentlich alle die gleiche Sprache?
Auch schwierig. So eine klassische Blablaka-Situation, Blablakamel, wo man dann einfach so,
Blablakamel! Meine Güte. Hast du mal Blablaka gemacht? Das ist für mich die Hölle. Das ist, glaube ich.
Doch einmal, da war ich wirklich extrem verzweifelt, das war so eine Orkan, alle Züge fallen aus, gar nichts geht mehr Situation,
wo ich dachte, okay, ich habe zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder ich gebe auf und grabe mir hier mein eigenes Loch und lege mich da rein oder ich gehe auf bla bla gra.de und habe es gemacht und habe dann auch jemanden gefunden und der war ganz, ja, der war okay. Aber das war dann auch so, wo ich gesagt habe, bitte no bla, bitte nicht und dann sitzt man da auch daneben und dann fängt man so einen Podcast an und ah, was hörst du, ja, herrngedeck und ah, worum geht's da, ich dachte eigentlich no bla, kann man denn anklicken, ob man bla will oder kein bla will? Ja genau, es gibt drei Stufen glaube ich, es gibt irgendwie richtig viel Bla. Drei Stufen? Das ist ja eigentlich die Idee von BlaBlaCar, dass du dich mit den Leuten connectest, die ein ähnliches Bla-Gefühl haben wie du. Wenn du sagst, okay, ich bin Bla-neugierig, ich will es mal ausprobieren, dann kannst du da Leute finden. Und man kommt halt zusammen. Und du bist halt dann als No-Bla bei einem Fahrer, der auch No-Bla ist. Aber das ist halt wie jeder Vertrag so. Ja, aber was der Vertrag, ja genau, missachtet ist die Gesellschaft, die nur seit Jahren vorschreibt, dass es unangenehm ist, wenn man sich anschweigt. Richtig. Das unterschlecht bla bla car. Und wie jeder Vertrag ist auch das halt ein Vertrag, der auf gutem Glauben basiert. Und am Ende sitzt er im Auto und er fängt an zu reden und er denkt, er, ich hab, das hab ich nicht, da hab ich nicht unterschrieben. Breach! Das ist ja wirklich so, Breach! Ich rfe jetzt meinen Anwalt an, was passiert jetzt, wie geht es weiter? Andreas K. Blatt. Aber das ist eigentlich auch die höchste Form des Sadismus, dich als Fahrer, als Nobler anzugeben und dann die gesamte Fahrt zu reden. Ein Wasserfall. Und dann, ja, ich war ja in meinem letzten Leben, war ich ja, und oh Gott, wir haben noch sechs und eine halbe Stunden vor uns. Oh Gott, Jesus. Und Stau. Ich glaube, ich laufe ab hier, ich glaube, ich steige auf der Autobahn aus. Das wäre spannend, wie weit geht denn Blablaka? Also es wird auch schon im Vorfeld überlegt, was man denn stattdessen macht. Das wäre interessant, das wäre so ein proaktives, wir verhindern wenigstens das unangenehme Schweigen. Nee, du kannst ja sagen, reden, Musik oder peinliches Schweigen. Und wenn du halt peinliches Schweigen anklickst und der andere auch peinliches Schweigen anklickst, dann kommt man zusammen, dann hat man halt it's a match und zwei so unglückliche Leute. Aber wenn du jetzt von Köln nach Flensburg willst und dann musst du jemanden finden, der genau deine Vorstellung, erst mal musst du jemanden finden, der von Köln nach Flensburg fährt, schwierig genug, dann musst du jemanden finden, der genau deine Blah-Vorstellungen hat, auch noblah, unpeinliche Schweigen angelegt hat und dann, wenn es gut läuft und die Uhrzeit auch noch stimmt, kommt man vielleicht von Köln nach Flensburg in der richtigen Zeit? Es ist schwierig, aber ich glaube, man kann auch Musikgeschmack angeben, halt dann so Hip-Hop der frühen 90er.
Ja, und der andere macht R'n'B und dann ist es vorbei, oder was? Lilly Allen einfach nur angeklickt. Da wundert sich, warum niemand jemals mit ihm matcht, aber weil er nur Lilly Allen ausgewählt hat. Obwohl das eigentlich, weil Tinder ist ja verbunden mit Facebook, eigentlich könnte man gut Tinder auch mit Spotify verbinden, oder? Dass man dann direkt so, ja, ist auch verbunden? Naja, man kann mittlerweile einen Song auswählen. Das ist mein Song. Ja, ist halt Eis Eis Baby immer, oder? Ist immer Eis Eis Baby, ja. Das ist mir auch schon negativ aufgefallen. Also wirklich, ich swipe und swipe und jeder ist immer Eis Eis Baby. Es gibt unglaublich, die Bilder bei Tinder sind, es gibt drei. Tredibrunnen, dann in Brüssel das Atomium.
Ja, und ein Gruppenfoto auf einer Party.
Und ein Gruppenfoto auf einer Party, ja.
Das sind die drei Motive.
Vielleicht nochmal hier irgendwo Holocaust-Denkmal oder sowas, aber das ist wirklich wenig.
Oder halt gecropptes Foto mit dem Ex-Freund.
Das ist auch immer gut.
Aber sein Gesicht ist ein Smiley.
Große, also dieser Herz-Smiley. Und du schaust diesem Smiley ins Gesicht und weißt, eines Tages werde ich du sein. Ach so, ich dachte, ah shit, gegen den komme ich nicht an. Ich komme jetzt. Ich bin, ich kann nicht so glücklich, so glücklich kann ich nie sein, ich bin nicht so ein positiver Mensch. Ich kann nicht gleichzeitig lachen und weinen. Ja, diese Herz, das geht nicht. Herzaugen, wie macht er das? Wie macht er das? Ja, das ist schwierig, aber du meintest, Frauen wollen süss genannt werden? Meintest du vorhin in deinem Stefans-Fick-Tipps-Segment? Was habt ihr damals im Podcast gesagt? Weiß ich doch nicht mehr, was ich vor zehn Minuten im Podcast gesagt habe. Ja genau, Stefans-Fick-Tipps, das ist die neue Rubrik dieses Jahr. Wobei, man muss sagen, ich habe, warte mal, ich habe gerade mein iPad vor mir. Du hast dein Textdokument aufgeführt. Nee, ich habe... War das ja 60 Seiten lang? Romantik-Tipps, Flirten, erstes Date, was ist das? Ich habe Bleigießen... Was ist das? Das sind Fotos, sind meine Fotos hier, warte, Achtung. Und zwar habe ich Bleießen gemacht dieses Jahr, Wachsgießen, weil soll man ja nicht mehr mit Bleigießen. Und wir mögen diesen Humor nicht, ist schon klar. Aber, und es ist ja, Bleigießen, es gehört ja auch dazu, dass man Dinge nicht erkennt. Dass man Dinge, dass man, Bleigießen ist ja immer so, alle machen abstrakte Formen. Ja. So, das ist doch nicht mehr, das ist einfach, es ist ein Penis. Das ist schon sehr nah dran. Aber es ist unglaublich nah dran. Also es kann, ohne Zweifel ist es ein Penis. Also ich glaube, wenn ein Skulpturkünstler mit der Menge Blei versuchen würde, einen Penis zu formen, sähe das genauso aus. Ja, wenn ich einen Penis gewollt hätte, hätte ich den genauso gemalt. Ja. Das ist alles daran stimmt. Auf der einen Seite, wenn du es halt umdrehst, kann es auch irgendwie so ein Beil sein oder ein Atompilz oder so. Weil du bist ja schon da noch fixiert auf die Perspektive. Wie du siehst, wenn ich das iPad drehe, dreht sich das Bild mit. Oder wenn du es seitlich siehst? Machen wir uns das vor. Es ist einfach eins zu eins im Penis. Es ist wirklich sehr lustig gewesen. Und das gibt es aber auch nicht, als hinten, lustigerweise bei Blackies hast du dann hinten auf der Verpackung die Legende, wo 15 Begriffe draufstehen. Und diese Begriffe sind alle Wörter, die dir einfallen. Das ist sehr faszinierend, weil hinten draufstehen wirklich maximal zwanzig Begriffe, manchmal 25. Baum steht drauf, Tier, sag mal irgendein Wort. Klumpen, unfähniger Bleiklumpen. Alles steht da drauf, wirklich. Und in dem Moment, das war wirklich sehr lustig, habe ich dann einem Kumpel, mit dem ich das gefeiert habe, Silvester gefeiert habe, habe ich eine Schachtel gegeben und alle Wörter, die mir gerade einfielen, so die erst, diese Top-of-your-head-Wörter, standen alle hinten drauf, auf diesen fünfzehn, das ist schon geil. Klingt nach einem verrückten Silvester, stört man. Es war das Klischee, normales Klischee-Silvester. Ist aber auch okay. Ich bin kein Fan von Silvester, das muss einfach weg. Nee, ich finde, man muss seine Erwartungen so weit runterdrehen, dass man gar nicht mehr ertäuscht werden kann, dann ist alles super. Generell im Leben. Ja, generell, aber das ist so einfach gesagt, natürlich geht das nicht. Ich erinnere mich noch, dass irgendwann mal, ich habe zweimal in meinem Leben Dating-Tipps bekommen, einmal von meinem Bruder und einmal von meiner Mutter. Und ich weiß noch, dass... Das ist ja auch ein ausgefallener Liebesleben. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wie. Aber ich glaube, durch irgendwas habe ich irgendwann mal gesagt, dass ein Mädchen gesagt hat, also da war ich ein Kind, wirklich ein Kind, Grundschule, dass ein Mädchen gesagt hat, dass ich süss bin. Und meine Mutter hat gesagt, oh, das ist ein gutes Zeichen, wenn ein Mädchen zu dir sagt, dass du süss bist. Und ich dachte so, Moment mal, Hallo, hallo, Mutter, da hast du was gesagt? Hallo, soll ich morgen meine Power Ranger Unterhose anziehen oder was? Heute Morgen geht's rund. Das war nicht eklig. Das ist extrem eklig, aber ja, es ist schwierig. Und dann bist du darauf eingestiegen, bist du dann da hingegangen zu dem Mädchen und hast gesagt, so und jetzt? Was genau hast du damit gemeint eigentlich? Ja. Im Sinne von süss. Weil ich würde mich eher als kräftig männlich herb bezeichnen. Ja. Weniger als süss. Was ist eher wie so ein... Wie meinest du das? Milder Typ. Ja, man hat ja auch in der Sekunde nicht die Möglichkeit, Komplimente zu hinterfragen, sondern es ist dann einfach so ein... Oh, du bist echt irgendwie so ein herber Typ. Okay, danke, ciao. Danke. Und auf dem Heimweg, was meinst du, herrb im Sinne von langweilig oder im Sinne von nicht aufregend oder ja, das ist schwierig, du musst ja Komplimente musst du erstmal annehmen, also Komplimente werden ja der Inhalt ist erstmal egal, ist komplett erstmal noch, wie es gesagt wurde. Genau, du musst erstmal entscheiden, nehme ich es an oder lehne ich es ab? Ja, genau. In der Regel nimmt man es an. Ja, sonst Konfrontation, also direkt erstmal annehmen. Sonst hat es ein Problem. Ja, genau, erstmal annehmen und dann nach. Ich nehme dieses Kompliment nicht an, dankeschön. Und dann ist natürlich auch die Frage, wenn du es angenommen hast, erwiderst du es reflexartig. Ah, du auch. Das ist bei mir oft auch so ein reflexartiges, was sowohl das Konterargument, Konterkompliment völlig nichtig macht, weil ich mein es ja offensichtlich nicht ehrlich, wenn jemand sagt, hey, tolle Schuhe, und ich sage, du hast auch tolle Schuhe. Ich habe noch nicht mal hingeschaut. Wie groß ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass ausgerechnet du das Teil an mir auch am besten findest. Neun Millionen Menschen auf der Welt, dass zwei die gute Schuhe tragen, sich genau da treffen. Aufeinandertreffen und genau gleich einen Geschmack haben. Komm schon, komm schon. Das und dann, das ist eigentlich alle Möglichkeiten, die man hat. Also Kompliment annehmen und dann entweder blind reflektieren. Wie beim Tennis damals, mit zuen Augen einfach zurückschlagen. Obwohl eigentlich besteht die Grossteil der Kindheit eigentlich aus, hä, du bist ein Dofi, du auch. Selber, Spiegel, Gummiband habe ich jetzt gelernt aus dem Herring-Deck-Podcast. Ja, erstmal zurückgeben, Dinge zurückgeben. Und so ist es bei Komplimenten auch eigentlich so. Ja, Komplimente, das funktioniert genau gleich auch wie Beleidigungen. Entweder du bist schlagfertig und brichst ein anderes Kompliment raus oder eine andere Beleidigung. Das ist genau das gleiche. Deswegen immer Komplimente über Dinge machen, die man selber nicht hat. Hey, cooler Gipser. Cooler Ohrring. Coole, schöne Ohrringe. Danke. Verdammt, du hast mich. Janett, du hast mich. Verdammt, oh mein. Ja, das stimmt schon. Was mir häufig rausrutscht, ist ein Danke gleichfalls. Weil wenn mir Leute Nettigkeiten entgegenbringen, will man die auch immer entgegenbringen. Und in dem Moment, wo halt eine Kellnerin zu mir kommt und sagt, guten Appetit, und ich sofort sage, ja danke gleichfalls. Viel Spaß beim Filmen. Danke Ihnen auch. Nee, ich werde nicht gucken, ich werde hier stehen und weiter Popcorn verteilen. Das, wie du siehst, wo man auch merkt, also wo man sich halt entlarvt und mit dieser nett gemeinten,
ich will einfach nur die Nettigkeit zurückspielen, ja alles zunichte machst, weil du dem gegenüber sagst,
du hast gerade so wenig Fokus in diesem Gespräch gehabt, gar keine Steaks in diesem Gespräch,
einfach nur, du wolltest einfach nur raus, dann machst du ja eigentlich alles kaputt.
Also zügelt euch vor jedem Dank gleichfalls. Werbung. Ey, ich bin so schlecht mit Technik. Echt? Ja, ich kenne mich überhaupt nicht aus. Allein wenn ich schon den Namen von so einem Laptop sehe, der irgendwie so zweieinhalb Seiten, allein der Name des Laptops ist, drehe ich komplett durch. Weisst du, wer dir helfen kann? Die jüng und Mädels von Cyberport. Oh, Cyberport, da haben wir während der Masterclass eingekauft, da haben wir schnell noch vor dem Dreh irgendwie noch so eine Speicherkarte geholt. Man muss nicht alles über Technik wissen, nur wenn man fragen kann, und Cyberport ist definitiv der richtige Ansprechpartner. Was haben die so im Sortiment? Unter anderem haben sie den neuen Dell XPS 15 und der funktioniert mit OLED-Technologie. Die ist ganz spannend, das ist eine organische LED-Technologie, die für blitzscharf, also so haarscharfe Bildqualität steht. Organische LED, also das ist dann irgendwie so eine Quallenhaut oder was ist dann auf dem Bildschirm drauf. Wie gesagt, man muss nicht alles über Technik wissen, geht zu Cyberboard, lasst dir da erklären. Nicht, dass die da irgendwie Mensch und Maschine kreuzen da in ihren Laboren oder so. Das kriegen die, glaube ich, gut hin.
Mit einem 15,6 Zoll Ultra HD 16 zu 9 OLED Display ausgestattet und verfügt über den neuen Prozessor, den Intel Core i7 der Generation 9. Und falls ihr mehr darüber erfahren möchtet, dann schaut doch einfach mal vorbei auf cyberport.de slash podcast ufo. Cyberport, die Antwort auf Technik. Werbung. Immer auch so dieses Augenkompliment ist immer so, da sagt man ja oft so, du hast schöne Augen oder so, das ist dann so ein, also will man für Dinge Komplimente kriegen, für die man nichts kann. Na ja doch, klar. Ja, einerseits schon, aber andererseits. Gerade die, weil du für die nichts kannst, die kannst du auch oft nicht ändern. Das sind ja Dinge, für die du nichts kannst, die kannst du auch nicht ändern. Ich dachte, man soll eher Komplimente machen für so, ah, schöne Schuhe oder schöne Frisur oder die Brille steht dir, sowas, wo man sich denkt, oh, ja, danke, das ist besser. Ich habe einmal, das war sehr gut, ich habe einmal in Kommen damit bekommen, dass ich eine schöne Stimme hätte. Ja. Und da dachte ich mir, das ist Dankeschön, da freue ich mich. Ja, aber da kannst du nichts für. Ciao. Und dann sage ich, du auch, ciao. Und dann bin ich hier gegangen. Dann haben haben wir nie wieder gesehen. Ja, dann hat diese hohe Fistelstimme, die nie wieder wieder gesehen wurde. Ciao, danke, ciao. Oh, danke gleichfalls. Welches Kompliment hat dir am besten gefallen, das du jemals bekommen hast? Womit kriegt man dich? Schöne Zähne, habe ich noch heute gehört. Mag ich sehr gern. Ja, finde ich auch gut. Das mag ich sehr gern, weil da habe ich was für getan, weil ich lange Zeit keine schöne Szene hatte, lange Zeit Zahnspangen getragen, also ich bin auch durch die Hölle gegangen für diese schönen Szene. Ja. Und deswegen ... Genau, man will dafür arbeiten, man will für etwas ein Kompliment bekommen, für das man auch gearbeitet hat. Was heißt gearbeitet, da haben jetzt natürlich die Metall ... Ja, was ich hasse ist, wenn ich ... Manchmal trage ich keine Brille, manchmal trage ich Kontaktlinsen. Mhm. Da höre ich häufig, ne, die Brille steht ja aber auch sehr gut.
Mit anderen Worten, Brille steht die besser.
Mit anderen Worten, je weniger man von deinem Gesicht sieht, desto besser siehst du aus.
Das mag ich nicht.
Was natürlich auch noch eine weitere Komplexitätsstufe obendrauf sind, sind Komplimente an Leute, die man...
Versteckt als trojanische Komplimente, wie ich sie nenne.
Auch das, aber ich rede auch von den Kamerakomplimenten.
Für Leute, die man manchmal in der Kamera oder im Fernsehen oder was auch immer sieht.
Und dann so, im Fernsehen wirkst du dicker. Und man denkt sich, so, jetzt müssen wir mal kurz nochmal anfangen. Das heißt, ich sehe dicker aus, als ich bin, in den Momenten, in denen ich eigentlich von werde und am besten aus. Jetzt gerade, wo ich privat bin und mich niemand sieht und erkennt, sehe ich besser aus. Und hast du das als Kompliment gemeint? Weil du denkst dir, okay, ich sehe, du bist dick, aber im Fernsehen bist du noch dick, also keine Chance. Jetzt bin ich dafür, man braucht einen Flyer hin. Jeder Mensch braucht so eine Bauchtasche, wo verschiedene Flyer auch drin sind. Unter anderem gibt es dann zum Ausfüllen, wie man beim Arzt bekommt oder beim Hotel, wenn man zum ersten Mal da ist, muss man Dinge ausfüllen, gibt es einen Komplimentschein, so einen Komplimentenprospekt. Und man hat nur eine gewisse Anzahl pro Tag, damit der andere auch weiß, dass es jetzt was wert ist, dass man nicht einfach jedem so ein Ding in die Hand drückt. Und da drauf steht oben Kompliment, also da kannst du das Handschifflich dann reinschreiben, vielleicht irgendwann mal digital. Du kannst es aber auch freilassen. Einfach nur als Kompliment. So ein leeres, weil das ist dann eigentlich so, danke. Ja, wollen wir erstmal die Grundregeln festnehmen, bevor wir die Metakategorie nach... Okay, aber man hat jeden Tag ein leeres, einmal in der Woche hat man ein Leeres. Okay, meinetwegen, ja, wenn du da so auf Behaar ist. Und da muss man oben ein Kompliment reinschreiben, da muss man ein paar Dinge ankreuzen. Also Kompliment gemeint unironisch, gemeint komplett ernst, gemeint als versteckte Beleidigung. Da muss man dann sein Kreuz setzen, dann diese ganzen Ungereimtheiten, die auftreten können bei Komplimenten, müsste man auch direkt vorwegnehmen.
Du hast nichts dafür getan, aber ist ja auch nicht schlimm, nimm es an.
Und Kompliment mit Hintergedanken. Also ist es nur ein Mittel zum Zweck.
Korrektiv. Es schlägt dahinter ein, ich will eigentlich an dir verändern.
Wenn ich sage, du hast aber heute gute Laune.
Genau.
Du hast sehr oft schlechte Laune. Ja genau, bei Kompliment mit Hintergedanken hast du dann nochmal die Auswahlmöglichkeiten, bitte verändere dich oder ich will mit dir schlafen. Ja. So einfach, damit du direkt weißt, wohin geht's in der Richtung, wie muss ich das jetzt hier einordnen. Und dann muss man drunter noch schreiben, trotzdem ernst gemeint oder nicht ernst gemeint, weil nur Hintergedanke. Genau. Und dann aber füllst du es dann aus vor der Person oder füllst du es schon davor aus und überreichst es dann nur? Im Idealfall, aber das ist es wirklich nur, wenn man vorher schon Zeit hat und weiß, dass man das Problem machen will, fände ich besser vorher ausfüllen, aber es ist völlig okay, es vor der Person auszufüllen. Ja. Und es ist auch völlig okay, wenn es, darf man nur maximal zehn Minuten in Zeit in Anspruch nehmen, weil alles andere war gemein. viel. Und dann aber man hat auch fünf Du-auch-Karten, die die andere Person einfach sofort zurückgeben kann. Und ich sehe mich schon. Einfach keine Komplimente machen. Keine Komplimente machen. Nicht mehr miteinander reden, das ist ja mein Vorschlag. Nee, einfach überhaupt nicht mehr. Es ist, vor allem die meisten sind nur in Gebracht einfach sagen, ja, haben wir alles, oder? Haben wir alles abgehakt. Ich habe hier in diesem Hotel das Problem gehabt, immer, dass mein Magnetportemonnaie diese Hotelsimmerkarte immer kaputt gemacht hat. Und ich jeden Abend nicht hier reinkam mehr. Glaubst du, ich habe was aktiv daran ändern wollen? Nein, weil es war so einfach, dieses Problem hier immer zu lösen. Ach, das ist dieser Kartenhaufen, der hier vor der Tür liegt. Man sagt unten Bescheid, die Karte geht nicht, dann geben die einem eine neue und das war mir dann auch nicht wert, nicht mal die Mühe aufzubringen, die Karte in eine andere Rosentasche zu peilen. Aber da gibt es nicht mehr so ein, das ist aber jetzt die letzte, Herr Tietze. Ja, okay. Aber gibt es gar keinen so einen Moment? Da gibt es eine gelbe Karte. Genau, erst die gelbe, die rote, dann muss er auf der Straße schlafen. Nee, kam gar kein Spruch. Gar kein Spruch? Nee, gar nicht. Die hochgezogene Augenbraue am Ende. Bei der fünften Karte kam ein... Ja, kein Geräusch. Nee, das stimmt nicht. Es war kein Geräusch, sondern die hochgezogene Augenbraue. Da muss man ja sehr vorsichtig sein. Dann hole ich Ihnen jetzt eine neue. Ach, okay. Ich baue eine neue, geil.
Der Magnet, Mensch, der mit dem fucking Magnet in der Tasche trottet.
Ja, beim Gehen ziehe ich dann noch so das Telefon von der Rezeption mit, weil es auch so an mir hängen geblieben ist.
Siehst den halben Raum so hinter dir.
Herr Tietz, ach Gott, lassen wir ihn laufen.
Er zieht so, ja, Aufzug geht nicht auf, okay.
Ja, nehmen Sie die Treppe, habe ich Ihnen schon mal gesagt. Okay, Aufzug bricht raus. Das Leben ist nicht leicht mit so einer Brieftasche, wie du eine hast. Das Leben ist nicht leicht. Nein, das Leben ist nicht leicht. Was ist mit der guten alten Katze, mit der Goldkatze, wo du einfach, also ein Beutel, einfach ein Beutel. Goldkatze? Ja, so heißt das halt, wo du deine Sachen drin hast. Du wärst perfekt für für so eine Zeitreise ins Mittelalter oder so. Du kennst sehr viele Begriffe. Ich glaube, du könntest dich sehr lange tarnen. Ich würde sehr schnell auffliegen. Man denkt ja immer diese romantische Vorstellung von Zeitreisen, wie man da rumrennt und so und hat eine gute Zeit. Nein, vor allem wirst du Probleme bekommen, weil du sofort auffliegst, egal wie du sprichst. Eben, du sprichst die Sprache auch einfach nicht. Das ist halt dein Altdeutsch und du, glaube ich, verstehst recht wenig. Naja, aber so, sag mal so. Also es kommt darauf an, was heißt Vergangenheit. Aber im 19. Jahrhundert würdest du, glaube ich, gut verstehen. Ja, das schon, das schon, wahrscheinlich schon. 18. Jahrhundert? Aber so davor, irgendwie, keine Ahnung. 18. Jahrhundert ist schon. Ich weiß nicht, denn so Altdeutsch zu Beowulf und so und dann verstehst du kein Wort mehr. So gefährliche Zeit im Beowulf. Nächste, was?. Was soll das? Ja, das ist das Schwierige. Das ist schwierig. Ach ja, ich war immer wieder in Wien. Wien ist eine ganz tolle Stadt. Ja, das war sehr schön. Vor allem wurde ich angeschrieben, weil ich ja dann auch ein Bild gepostet habe bei Instagram, und da wurde ich angeschrieben von einer Tourismusseite in Wien, die gesagt haben, oh, was treibt dich denn immer wieder in unser schönes Wien? Da habe ich mich sehr gefreut, da habe ich lange formuliert und überlegt, was kann ich alles für Komplimente machen an Wien,
habe dann ein bisschen was geschrieben und zurückkam, schade, ich dachte, ihr dreht hier die neue Staffel eurer Serie.
Und das ist so ein bisschen ein Stich ins Herz, in mein überzuckertes KaiserschmarrenHerz, weil ich dachte, ja gut, dann lasst das einfach auch und jetzt schon mal gar nicht. Aber Wien ist wirklich toll, da ticken die Ohren einfach ein bisschen anders. Das ist wirklich wie so eine kleine Zeitreise. Man lehnt sich immer so ein bisschen zurück, man läuft so ein bisschen zurückgelehnt. Mein Problem ist, ich komme selten zur Ruhe, ich bin noch nicht im Jetzt, ich bin nie im Jetzt. Und in Wien bin ich im Jetzt, war ich im Dann eher. Wieder Plusquam perfekt. Ich war im Dann gewesen. Ich war im Jetzt gewesen. Ich finde aber, man kann eine Kultur am besten daran beurteilen, was die höchsten Gebäude der Stadt sind. Richtig. Ja, oder ich wollte was komplett anderes sagen. Ich verstehe schon. Sehr gewagt von dir, meinen Satz zu verfolgt. Das ist ähnlich, wenn man immer all in geht, wenn man mal redet mit Leuten, es ist ja lustig, man Dialoge auch schreibt, ist ja immer, einer spricht fertig, der andere spricht fertig, der andere spricht auch zu Ende. Das passiert nie. Die ganze Zeit fällt man Leuten ins Wort und beendet Sätze undw. Der andere findet ein Wort nicht, der andere greift ein.
Man kann das Gespräch direkt zerstören, wenn man wie ich jetzt einfach bewusst immer all in geht.
Ich finde, am besten kann man eine Kultur ja immer daran beurteilen, was sie in ihren Automaten verkauft.
Jede Kultur, du bist enttäuscht, jede Gesellschaft hat andere Automaten.
Und deswegen fand ich es ganz fantastisch, was kann man in Wien in Automaten kaufen?
Und? Geige.
Brote. Ganze
leibe Brote.
Als wir das letzte Mal hier in Wien waren für die Live-Show,
habe ich Automaten gesehen, wo man
ganzen Leib Brot kaufen kann.
Frisches Brot,
Automat, aber jetzt nicht irgendwie so Backautomat
in einem Backshop oder sowas, sondern wirklich auf der Straße stehend, wo du einfach gute Brote dir rausnehmen kannst, wo ich dachte so, das beschreibt für mich schon mal die Kultur.
So, ja, in Deutschland, da gibt es dann halt irgendwie so den Kaugummiautomaten, Zigarettenautomaten und sowas, aber in Wien, ich meine natürlich legendär in Japan natürlich, vielleicht ist das auch nur ein Urban Myth oder so, halt der Unterwäscheautomat oder so, oder dann so Fingernägel, die du kaufen kannst und so ein Kram. Aber auch da, man sieht es an einem Automaten. Und in Wien hast du den schönen Brotautomaten. Ich weiß nicht, da müssen wir vielleicht auch mal bei Antenne Afrika nachhaken, welche Automaten gibt es in den afrikanischen Ländern? Ich glaube, ja, viele sind froh, wenn sie den Genuss eines Automaten überhaupt kämen. Wieso? Nee, das ist ja auch unsere Aufklärungsrubrik, wo wir auch mal ein bisschen aufmerksam machen sollten, dass es vielen afrikanischen Staaten vielleicht nicht so gut geht. Aber gute Frage. In Südafrika wird wahrscheinlich eine Menge Automaten haben. Auf jeden Fall. Richtig viele Automaten. Und es gibt ja viele verschiedene Automaten. Ich mag ja auch so diese Automaten, so diese Futterautomaten. Finde ich ja ganz geil. Ja, für Tiere, Tierfutter. Und es gibt bei mir in der Umgebung, wo ich aufgewachsen bin, gibt es einen, es ist kein richtiger Bauernhof, es ist einfach ein grosses Haus, das random drei Hühner hat oder so. Es hat kein Land. Auch kein Recht theoretisch, was wir zu meinen Beanspruchungen verkaufen müssen.
Und ich habe damals schon gedacht, warum hat man drei Hühner so, was passiert da genau?
Und warum meint man dann damit auch ein Geschäft zu machen?
Und die hatten dann irgendwann drei Hühner und zwei Ziegen.
Und die waren an so einem Weg, wo halt viele Wanderer vorbeigelaufen sind und haben dann irgendwann so einen Futterautomaten da installiert. Und die haben da wirklich für drei Ziegen sich so einen Futterautomaten geholt. Haben gedacht, so den schaffen wir uns jetzt an. Wir investieren mal tausend Mark und einmal füttern eine Mark. Und über wie viel Jahrzehnte muss das laufen, damit das sich lohnt? Und dann war da dieser private Futterautomaten. Ich fand das immer so faszinierend. Ich finde es eine gute Idee. Dass man da einfach, wenn man vorbeiläuft und sagt, oh Z Ziegen, oh, die fütter ich. Und die Ziegen halt einfach, die haben natürlich halt auch gearbeitet, die waren halt die Komplizen. Also, oh, oh, bist du so hungrig? Moment, hat die Ziegen gerade gesprochen? Ziegen haben andere Akzente. Das ist auch ein neuer Funfact. Deswegen kann man sie so schwer verstehen, meinst du, oder was? Aber Ziegen haben je nachdem, wo sie aufwachsen, wie Kühe, unterschiedliche Akzente. Und die verstehen sich auch erstmal nicht mit der Herde, aber die gewöhnen sich dann an den Akzent. Wenn man eine Ziege dann irgendwo anders hinsetzt, kommt die erst nicht klar, wird auch ausgestossen und dann irgendwann aber nimmt sie den Akzent der Herde an wieder und dann ist gut. Bei Kühen ist es ähnlich. Aber können Tiere denn andere Tiersprachen lernen? Also so rudimentär? Das finde ich total spannend. Also ich finde das schon spannend. Verstehen Möpse Dackel? Verstehen Dackel, Golden Retriever? Ja. Weil es ist ja theoretisch, ja, wie nah muss der Karnis, der gemeine Hund, mit dem anderen versandt sein, damit sie die gleiche Sprache sprechen. Ja, finde ich spannend. Oder dann auch so irgendwie so ein Esel und Pferd oder dann so Maultier und Pferd, verstehen die sich untereinander? Kamel, Dromedar. Oder ist es dann so ein bisschen der weirde Cousin irgendwie, wo man so nur die Hälfte versteht, so durchs Gebrabbel? Schwierig. Aber müssen die dann nicht Affen auch verstehen zum Teil? Also verstehen wir auch nicht. Wir sind glaube ich far away, wir sind einfach weiter gelaufen.
Es ist schon komisch, dass es von Menschen so wenige Arten gibt, also so Neandertaler ausgestorben, ich meine von allen anderen Tieren, also auch von wilden Tieren. Wir sind die einzigen mit dem Gendefekt Schlauheit.
Ja, es gibt so viele verschiedene Affen, es gibt so viele verschiedene Würmer und so.
Also gibt es denn, wie viele andere Tierarten gibt es denn, wo es nur eine einzige, ich sage jetzt Spezies, ich kenne mich jetzt biologisch nicht genau aus, deswegen sage ich jetzt mal Spezies, also Homo, Sapiens, Spezies oder Rasse von mir aus. Wo es wirklich nur eine gibt, also ich kenne mich überhaupt gar nicht mit dem Thema aus, aber gibt es selbst Tiger oder so, da gibt es doch bestimmt den Weissen, den Gelben und halt den, der Basketball spielt. Tiger. Tiger, ja und Tiger gibt es auch noch, es gibt den Frucht-Tiger, da gibt es auch einige. Aber ich finde, also hat das was damit zu tun, weil der Mensch ist ja schon speziell auf eine Art, ohne dir zu nahe treten zu wollen. Nee, ich würde mich da so angucken. Ist das gar nicht böse gemeint? Diese Handgeste, diese von oben bis unten Handgeste ist speziell, fand ich halt selten. Besonders. Ja, besonders, genau. Kannst du kurz diesen Komplimentantrag hier ausfüllen? Menschen sind halt besonders. Hängt es damit zusammen, dass sie dann auch nur noch eine Rasse, eine Spezies gibt? Ich glaube, es gab noch eine Menge und dann haben die Sicherheitser, es hat einfach die Cleverste über gewonnen und hat dann die anderen zerstört. Und jetzt am Ende ist dann nur eine übergeblieben, die halt, weil wir halt auch besonders sind, wir sind ja auch, glaube ich, mit am meisten entfernt von allen anderen Tieren. Aber die, aber Homo sapiens haben ja die Neandertaler nicht ausgerottet, oder? Die haben ja die nicht aufgefressen oder so. Ich glaube doch, getötet, getötet. Alle umgebracht. Weiß ich nicht.
Ja, denke schon. Haben einfach nicht überlebt dann mehr und konnten sich nicht genug fortpflanzen. Ich glaube ja, dass der Mensch ja auch sich so weit entwickelt hat, ist ja glaube ich kein Zufall, dass die einzige, sagen wir mal dann auch, wie nennen wir das, Spezies, die alleine ist, auch die Spezies ist, die am Wahrscheinlich am meisten auch jetzt mittlerweile genetisch von den anderen Tieren, sind wir genetisch weiter von Affen entfernt zum Beispiel als andere Tiere ihrer Gattung. Ja. So sind, sagen wir mal, Kugelfische näher an, findet Nemo-Fischen, Klaunfischen, als wir an Affen. So, ich glaube nicht, ich glaube, wir sind deutlich weiter vom Affen entfernt. Es ist merkwürdig, weil ich musste manchmal lange verteidigen, weil ich habe mal ein Video gemacht über Evolution, und unter jedem Video über Evolution, also Evolution erklärt, gibt es natürlich ganz viele Kommentare, wie Evolution gibt es nicht, ist nur eine Theorie, wissenschaftlich nicht fundiert, bla bla bla. Und dann musste ich mit denen argumentieren. Und dann gibt es ein Phänomen, das heißt Ringspezies. Und zwar gibt es da so, stell dir mal so eine Insel vor, mit einem grossen Berg in der Mitte. Und wenn du ganz oben auf der Insel bist... Kann ich auch zwei Berge? Nein, Stefan, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, hier hast du die Karte, hör auf zu singen. Ja. Ich habe mir extra welche trocken lassen. Sorry, sorry. Und jetzt kannst du entweder rechts um den Berg rumlaufen, um nach unten zu kommen, oder links um den Berg rumlaufen, ne, verstehst du? Ich liebe es Riesel jetzt schon. So, und jetzt gibt es das Phänomen, dass eine, sagen wir mal, eine Vogelart fängt oben an. Und dann breitet sich diese Vogelart nach links aus und nach rechts aus, ja. Also die einen gehen links um den Berg rum und die anderen gehen rechts um den Berg rum. Über hunderte Jahre, hunderte Jahre, Millionen Jahre verteilen sich diese links und rechts rum. Und wenn die sich unten wieder treffen, dann kann es vorkommen, dass die sich so weit verändert haben, dass die sich nicht mehr miteinander fortpflanzen können. Dann sind es andere, ich weiss jetzt nicht genau dieses Wort, aber sagen wir mal Spezies, sind es, weil ich glaube, so ist es ja definiert, wenn man sich nicht miteinander fortpflanzen kann, dann ist man eine andere Spezies oder sowas. Dann, also das ist ja so, oder da habe ich ja gesagt, so das ist klarer Beweis für Evolution, dass die sich so weit weiterentwickeln und verändern, dass sie sich nicht miteinander fortpflanzen können. Warum passiert sowas bei Menschen nicht?
Weil es kann ja jeder Mensch sich mit jedem anderen Menschen auf der Welt fortpflanzen.
Warum gibt es da nicht irgendwie eine Insel, wo irgendwie über tausende Jahre, wahrscheinlich ist der Mensch noch zu jung, oder?
Ja, ich glaube, im Vergleich dazu, wie alt auch die Erde zum Beispiel ist,
ist der Mensch ja nur eine Manosekunde.
Staubkorn.
Ja, beide Beispiele waren, glaube ich, kompletter Bullshit. Eine Nanosekunde, auch in welchem Spektrum. Wenn die Erde eine Stunde lang alt, eine Stunde alt ist. Ja, erst mal die Erde ist so alt wie eine Folge Alf. Dann werden die Menschen so am letzten Namen des Abspanns, so das Senderlogo, das werden die Menschen. Aber das aber auch nur in den Nanosekunden, ganz kurz. Und das nur ein Staubkorn. Also wenn du den ganzen Bildschirm hast, nur ein Staubkorn davon. Ja, für eine Nanosekunde der Staubkorn, das sind wir auf der Erde. Und ich glaube, da war einfach noch nicht genug Zeit, um sich weiterzuentwickeln. Aber es könnte passieren, oder? Also wenn jetzt irgendwie Menschen so in der Insel, also ich meine natürlich heute, es gibt zu viele Reisen und so, aber es gibt ja auch so Dschungelstämme, die wirklich unberührt sind seit wahrscheinlich tausenden Jahren. Aber wie sollen die sich denn grossartig weiterentwickeln auf diesem kleinen Inselchen? Na die passen sich halt an die Umgebung an, keine Ahnung, die haben dann halt Flügel, keine Ahnung, halt so Mutationselektion mässig sind die halt ein bisschen anders aus. Oh mein Gott, und es wäre schlimmer vor, und dann haben die Flügel entwickelt. Und du denkst dir, warum haben die Flügel? Kann man das nicht aktiv machen, dass man so sagt, oder sind wir nicht sogar, sind wir nicht Teil. Nee, du musst halt einfach nur in der Gesellschaft Leitern verbieten. Ja genau. Dann warte mal zwei, dreieinhalb Jahre. Nee, du setzt dich auf so einer spitzen Insel aus, auf so einer, wo das Futter, also es sind so ganz viele spitze Berge, die du nicht hochklettern kannst und oben ist das Futter. Ja, so Celebrations, Snickers bauen die für jeden was dabei. Ja, genau, aber du nimmst die Darth weg, weil die will keiner, die helfen uns nicht, die Snickers und die Mars und die Milky Way. Okay. Legen wir oben, ja, muss ich nur sagen. Ja, Twix aber auch. Ja, Twix auch. Okay. Und dann legt man die oben auf diese Berge und dann wartet man, bis Leute Flügel entwickelt haben. Und jetzt kommt, Achtung, Mindfuck, was wenn wir exakt dieses Experiment sind auf der Erde? Weil Aliens brauchten Leute, die auf einem Wasserplaneten klarkommen, auf einem Wassersteinplaneten klarkommen. Also du meinst, wenn wir, also vielleicht wurde ja damals, als wir auf dem Mond gelandet sind, ja auch da so eine Käseplatte gefunden oder so, als Belohnung, die die Aliens da hingelegt haben. Aber die Nase hat das natürlich verheimlich, weil das schlecht aussieht. Merz ja peinlich ist, weil unangenehme Geschichte auch irgendwie. Da lag so eine Merci und dann mit so einer Schrift, die so leicht anders war, aber so leicht, aber man konnte sie immer noch lesen. Ja, aber so ein bisschen Fraktur-Nazi-Schrift. Und man denkt sich, Sekunde mal. Ja, aber das Logo war auch, also Merci einfach. Und man denkt, weil ich glaube mittlerweile, Merci ist so universell verständlich. Das ist unverfänglich auch. Aber haben die nicht sogar so eine Packung Merci ins All geschossen oder so? Nee, genau eben nicht. Ich denke, das hätten die machen sollen. Die haben ja die Black Eyed Peas, wo man sagt, okay, falsch zu verstehen. Aber I got a feeling, da oben durchs All bersten. Da oben nimmst du eine Band, die so heisst wie Essen. Ja. Wie fucking verwirrend kann man den Aliens hin machen. Schick Toffifee oder Messie in den Himmel, das ist einfach unverfänglicher. Dann würden die Danke sagen, aber auch so, wie man halt zu einer Packung Messi, Danke sagt. So unermusional. Das ist ja okay. Nicht schlecht, aber auch nicht gut. Ist Messi mit dabei schon eine Art Beleidigung eigentlich, weil es so der Gipfel der egalen Geschenke ist? Ja. Es ist noch eine gute Geste eigentlich. Nee, ich glaube, es ist eine gute Geste, aber es gibt halt auch, glaube ich, dann so bei Lidl so Grazie oder so, halt so die Fake-Messi. Das ist ein Beleidiger. Das ist ein Fick-Dicht. Ich kann es genau so gefick-Dicht nennen. Das ist dann, glaube ich, so. Du kannst dir niemanden Messie für mich leisten. Das ist dann wirklich beleidigend, glaube ich. Also da würde ich dann auch wirklich sofort umdrehen. Ich war auch ein paar Tage in Rom jetzt am Anfang des Jahres. Ich musste den ganzen Urlaub nachholen und da kam die ganze Zeit nicht aus meinem Spanisch raus. Und man muss sagen, ich bin auch im Spanischen auch nicht drin. Ich kam aus meiner Sprache nicht raus, aus der ich auch nicht drin bin. Und was die ganze Zeit dazu führte, dass ich immer Gracias gesagt habe und Hola und das war schon unangenehm wirklich, also bei immer den Nader gesagt. Es gibt ja immer so einen im Flugzeug, im Flug nach Rom und du siehst ja neben dir Blätter zu durchs Deutsch, Spanisch, Spanisch, Deutsch und du denkst dir, soll ich ihn ansprechen? Soll ich ihm sagen? Soll ich sagen, Rom liegt nicht in Spanien? Madre del Dios! Ja. Und fängt an zu fluchen. Hijo de puta! Ja. Es ist schwierig. Es ist wirklich schwierig manchmal. Aber hast du eine schöne Zeitgeib im Rom? Hast du das Kolosseum angeschaut? Ich habe das Kolosseum angeschaut. Hast du den Magna Romus Opus Magnum? Hast du Eisse gegessen? Ja, ich habe Eisse gegessen. Na, Deutsche Vita genossen. Deutsche, Deutsche Vita vor allem. Tatsächlich waren wir am Kolosseum. Es war sehr schön, sehr interessant, weil ich dachte die ganze Zeit, das ist ja wirklich einfach wie ein modernes Stadion gebaut, was daran liegt, weil die modernen Stadien ja auch, also erstmal, wie soll ein Stadion auch sonst aussehen, in der Mitte ist was und außen ist was anderes. Ja, ja. Vielmehr ist das Kolossium ja nicht als Ränge und ein Platz in der Mitte.
Naja, es ist schon eine Entscheidung, weil ich meine, wenn du ein Theater baust, dann baust du das Spektakel hoch.
Ja, ja. Also Ränge und Platz in der Mitte. Naja, es ist schon eine Entscheidung, weil ich meine, wenn du ein Theater baust, dann baust du das Spektakel hoch, Publikum niedrig. Bei einem Stadion ist es andersrum, da ist das Spektakel tief, Publikum hoch. Das ist ja schon eine Designentscheidung. Naja, es ist ja schon pragmatisch in dem Sinne, dass die maximal viele Leute sollten zuschauen. Da haben irgendwie auch 60.000 Leute reingepasst, das war richtig gross. Aber wäre es nicht besser, wenn du einfach den Löwen auf eine 100 Meter hohe Bühne tust und die ganze Stadt kann zuschauen? Da musst du viel weniger bauen. Kann sie ja nicht. Siehst du doch. Die ganze Stadt sieht doch den Kölner Dom. Wenn du auf den Kölner Dom jetzt den Löwen stellst, dann kann die ganze Stadt den sehen. Nein, habe ich gerade gesagt. Gegenüber passiert etwas ganz spannendes. Gegenüber läuft gerade jemand mit einer Taschenlampe umher. What? Gegenüber in dem, und es ist immer Einbrecher. Warum sollte man so eine Taschen-Oder ist entweder Taschen-Dieb? Dieses Fenster zum Hof, wir wissen nicht, ob wir eingreifen sollen. Da läuft jemand mit einer Taschenlampe umher, siehst du das? Guck mal, gegenüber hier direkt, da. Aber in der... Das ist das Fenster zum Hof. Aber da brennt auch ein bisschen Licht. Also Stromausfall, warum Taschenlampen sind immer gefährlich in Wohnungen. Dieb, müssen wir jetzt die Polizei anrufen. Wir haben das Thema gehabt, Lehrer Kinderwagen, haben schon Leute gesagt, ist schon eine Polizei, jetzt macht Florentin, mach die Taschenlampe an. Das sieht einfach aus, als ob du ganz viele Fotos machst. Okay, Florentin morst, macht das Licht an und aus, aber er morst halt wie so ein Kleinkind spricht wahrscheinlich. Da ist kein Alphabet dahinter oder keine Wörter, es ist einfach nur an, aus, an, aus. Er hat aufgehört. Er hat aufgehört. Ja, er hat aufgehört. Ja, weil er jetzt ertappt ist. Es sieht aus, als ob du Fotos von ihm gemacht hättest. Habe ich aber letztens gesehen, ganz fantastische neue Erfindungen. Wir wollen natürlich auch die deutschen Entdecker unterstützen. Und da gab es in einem Supermarkt, in dem ich eingekauft habe, ein Regal Erfindungen aus Höhle der Löwen. So konnte man da kaufen. Und eine Erfindung war der Anwesenheitssimulator. Ich glaube, so hieß es. Anwesenheitssimulator. Und das ist so eine Art Disco-Kugel, sage ich jetzt mal, die Licht erzeugt in deinem Haus, als wären Leute im Haus.
Und zwar erzeugen die diese schwarzen Schatten, wenn Menschen an einem Fenster vorbeigehen.
Du bist zu der Welt, wenn die angeht und du bist noch da.
Also die sehen so ein bisschen aus wie Diskokugel und dann haben sie diese Schatten, also die machen überall Licht, ausser an dem Punkt, wo der Schatten dann ist. Und dann simulieren die anwesend als, ja doch, habe ich gesagt, anwesend als Simulator. Und dann tun die so als... Wie auch willst du noch erstaunt tun, dass aufs Wort kommt und das gleiche Wort sagt. Ja, es ist so, mein Herz sagt nein, mein Kopf sagt ja. Es fühlt sich falsch an, aber mein Kopf... Es fühltlt sich nach der falschen Idee auch an. Aber warum sagt es nicht einfach ganz laut, wie so, hallo, wir sind hier.
Entschuldigung, wohnen Sie hier?
Die ganze Zeit, aber die ganze Zeit so diese Sätze wie, hallo, war da was? Habe ich gerade was gehört? Nein, nein, da hast du dich wohl getäuscht.
Hallo, Entschuldigung, wir rufen die Polizei, sie melden, sie kommen raus bei drei, eins, zwei, hallo, Entschuldigung, man kann auch einfach, die Nachbarn halten die so die Kissen über die Ohren, weil die ganze Zeit, hallo, aus dem Nachbarhaus bläht die ganze Zeit, Entschuldigung, drei Uhr nachts, die ganze Nacht. Die Wild sind wieder im Urlaub. Hallo? Was war das gerade? Ist da wer? Hallo? Ich sehe sie doch. Wie lang muss dieser Loop sein? Nee, ihr könnt einfach, wenn ihr fahrt, diesen Podcast hier laut laufen lassen in eurer Wohnung und einfach diesen Clip immer wieder spielen. Wie lang muss der Loop sein, bis der Einbrecher irgendwann merkt nach dem Hallo, das ist ertäuschend echt. Bei Tapeten, so riecht ja auch immer die Loops. Ja, genau. Das ist immer spannend, dann zu entdecken, wo sind denn dann... Ja, und auch so bei Fliesen und so, wenn man sich denkt, das ist kein echtes Marmor, das ist Fake. Aber die werden wahrscheinlich ... Das ist genau wie den Chicken Nuggets. Bei Chicken Nuggets gibt es ja, glaube ich, so sechs Formen. Ja, Boot, Bell, Bone. Stimmt, hatten wir mal. Bone, Boot, Bell und Ball. Ball, Bull, Bell, Bell and Bell. Wahnsinn, nicht schlecht. Und je mehr Chicken Nuggets man hat, desto einfacher ist es, dieses Muster zu finden. finden. Aber ja, das habe ich auf jeden Fall gesehen und dachte mir auch, ja, das ist die Innovationsspeerspitze Deutschlands. Gerät, das du tut, als wärst du zu Hause. Hast du es jetzt? Ich habe es nicht. Um dich manchmal nicht alleine zu fühlen und in Schatten huschen vorbei. Mega Idee eigentlich. Ne, das ist... Naja, ein bisschen quatschig. Also wie gesagt, da gibt es auch viele andere Ideen. Tatsächlich, ich gebe den Credit weiter, wo der Credit weitergegeben werden muss. Der Lieblingswitz von meinem Vater. Ja. Was ist das für ein Reusperer? Ich zitiere Reusperer. Ja. Jetzt kommt ein Witz. Familie macht sich auf den Weg, das Haus zu verlassen. Fragt die Mutter besorgt. Oh, Schatz, sollen wir nicht das Licht anlassen für die Einbrecher? Sagt der Vater. Ach nee, brauchst du nicht, die haben bestimmt Taschenlampen. Warum fehlen in Sätzen von Witzen immer Wörter? Familie geht aus, fragt Fritzchen. Ja, das war ein bisschen Hölzern vorgetragen, das ist ja nicht zu. Nein, warum sind Witz, aber das ist ja die Witzformel. Fragt Fritzchen, das ist ja immer, in Witzbüchern steht ja auch immer, fehlen ja Wörter. Ja, Fritzchen fragt. Ja, diese verbindenden Wörter, diese daraufhin, dann und so viel einfach immer. Familie geht aus, fragt der Vater.
Sie hörten den Lieblingswitz meines Vaters, vielen Dank an der Stelle. Aber ganz interessant, ich habe über die Weihnachtstage ein fantastisches Buch gelesen, und zwar von dem Autoren, da stand auch Kinnrug drin, und zwar der Autor Victor Klemperer, und zwar war der Jude im Dritten Reich und hat in Deutschland gelebt während der gesamten Zeit, er war privilegierter Jude und hat den Weltkrieg überlebt. Und der war Romanist und Sprachwissenschaftler, konnte aber nichts lesen und nicht lernen während der Nazizeit, weil er Jude war. Und deswegen hat er sich zur Aufgabe gemacht, die Sprache des Dritten Reichs zu analysieren und zu dokumentieren, wie die Sprache sich verändert hat und was man da für sprachliche Mittel findet und wie es ist und grossartig. Auch sehr relevant heutzutage. Wahnsinn, das Buch heißt LTI, Lingua Tertia Imperio, also die Sprache des Dritten Reichs, aber weil die Nazis auch immer viel abgekürzt haben, hat er das auch abgekürzt zu LTI. Und er fand Dinge, weil man weiß ja immer nicht, wie die Sprache damals war, das war einfach nur so, weil es alt ist oder war es so einfach, weil es dieser bestimmte Sprache brauchst. Grandioses Buch, auch die Tagebücher von Viktor Klemperer auch fantastisch. Gibt es auch als Hörbuch, gibt es auch kostenlos von Radio, könnt ihr euch kostenlos anhören, die Tagebücher von Viktor Klemperer. Und der hat auch beschrieben, wie sich das, und er hat als Anglizismus beschrieben, dass der Artikel wegfällt. Wenn du zum Beispiel sagst, Feind hört mit, dann hat er gesagt, das ist ein Anglizismus, das ist ein Amerikanismus, ja, Enemy Listens oder so, wo man vor dem Dritten Reich immer noch gesagt hat, der Feind hört mit. Und diesesfallen des Artikels wurde als Teil der Nazisprache oder der Sprache des Dritten Reichs analysiert.
Wenn man das als Anglizismus versteht, glaube ich, dann sind wir schon fast im Englischen mittlerweile im Deutschland angekommen.
Weil man muss sagen, es ist ja so krass, wie die englische Sprache die ganze Popkultur auf der Welt gerade vereinnahmt,
auch durch sowas wie, weil man sich auf Englisch geeinigt hat im Internet, also auch Nein-Gag und sowas
oder halt Filme
etc.
Memes, Twitter, Facebook und
das ist ja auch so, mir wird häufig vorbegehoffen
von meinem Chef, der dann
häufig der Erste ist, der die Drehbücher liest
und noch die unfertigen, ungepolishten
Drehbücher
und der behauptet immer zu erkennen,
wenn ich was geschrieben habe, weil halt durch mein Alter Also, das ist ein Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich in den Schuss, der sich inücher. Und der behauptet immer zu erkennen, wenn ich was geschrieben habe, weil halt durch mein Alter ich, glaube ich, schon so im Englischen drin bin, und auch weil ich ja vor allem auch schon fast nicht mehr mit synchronisierten Filmen gross geworden bin, sondern jetzt ja auch schon fast wieder mit Originalfassungen, ähm, im Grossteil meines Lebens, dass man raushört, wenn ich einfach englische Begriffe oder englische Wortkonstruktionen einfach eins zu eins übernehme, weil die für mich schon normal klingen, für ihn noch nicht. Und das ist schon spannend. Ich glaube, mittlerweile übernimmt man ja, wie du schon sagst, Feind hört mit, da ist ja kein englisches Wort mit drin, also nicht, was man gemeint als Anglissismus bezeichnen würde, aber alles daran ist ja englisch.
Und ich glaube, Grammatik übernimmt man total, das vergisst man meistens.
Aber die englische Sprache ist auch so wahnsinnig praktisch, allein so was wie isch, dieses irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Quentin Tarantino isch oder halt so ähnlich wie.
Das kriegst du einfach nicht hin im Deutschen, das ist einfach so esk, aber dann keine Ahnung, so do you wanna go and use your no-ish oder so. Also du kannst so diese Abwägungen, so diese Spektren abbilden, dieses isch. Das ist so fantastisch, dieses isch ist so, aber was ich auch wichtig finde, ist out, also zum Beispiel to outnerd someone, also jemanden, der grössere Nerd als jemand anders sein, to out-nerd somebody. Outsmart somebody. To outsmart, dieses out, weil das kannst du an jedes Wort dranhängen. Ja, ja. To out-mom. Die ist viel praktischer. My mom out-mom's your mom, sowas. Das ist grossartig. Die ist wie so ein Set, also das ist ein Set aus wenigen Teilen. Ja. Das ist wie so ein Werkzeugkoffer, wo du verschiedene Sachen, Lego, wie so ein Lego-Baukasten, aber wohingegen du im Deutschen baust du dieses, meinetwegen die Lego Ritterburg und das Englische ist halt so ein Grundbaustein-Set. Da kannst du alles mitb bauen, vielleicht alles nicht so ausgeschmückt und gross, aber du kannst ein Schloss bauen. Du kannst aber auch eine Burg bauen, einen Baum bauen, ein Tier. Im Deutschen kannst du nur, du brauchst halt jedes Set für alles, weil es ist immer darauf aufgebaut. Auch bei Sätzen weißt du am Anfang ja oft schon, wie sie enden und so weiter, weil die Sprache so gebaut ist. Mich würde mal interessieren, was Engländer und Amerikaner an der deutschen Sprache beneiden. Wir wissen wahrscheinlich, dass die deutsche Sprache auch ganz viele solche tollen Mittel hat, aber die merken wir natürlich nicht, weil wir es gewohnt sind. Das würde mich mal interessieren, was die sagen, so etwas bräuchten wir auch im Englischen oder so. Falls ihr Native Speaker seid oder euch gut auskennt, schreibt gerne mal in die Kommentare. Ja, genau. Ich habe auch wieder klassische Musik gesehen in Wien und auch eine Oper, eine auf Deutsch. Und das ist schon auch interessant, wie die Sprache sich da geändert hat, hier und da. Aber ab und zu hat eine Figur gesagt, ich bin's, hi, ich bin's, mässig. Wo man auch denkt, wo man sich kurz erschreckt, wenn man denkt, das ist sehr nah dran, was sehr gruselig ist, weil es fast 200 Jahre her ist. Aber Sie haben schon noch Ich bin's gesagt, ne? Ich bin's. Nicht Ich bin's. Also da war Wagner noch nicht. Ich bin's. Da war es noch nicht. Gut, das ist doch schon was schön. Brünnhilde! Dabt da schon jemand wieder? Aber es ist manchmal auch so leicht, er hat ja auch mal mit dem Gesang gehört, dass es manchmal leicht ist, auch in der deutschen Sprache zu faken, etwas artistischer darstellen zu lassen, als es tatsächlich ist. Oder cleverer zu wirken. Du kannst ja einfach sagen, reiche den Revolver mir und man klingt sofort literarisch und in einem Buch. Ja, aber im Amerikanischen wechselst du ins britische Englisch. Genau, sowas hast du nicht. Ja, genau, aber hört mal Game of Thrones und einfach nur, wie lassen wir die Figuren alt? Ja, ja, genau. Ja, wir lassen sie britisch sprechen. Der ist besonders böse. Was machen wir damit? Also Dialogbuchautoren von beispielsweise Game of Thrones, die Deutschen, die müssen richtig arbeiten. Ja, ja, du kannst ja einfach Sächsisch oder irgendwie andere Dialekte machen. Ja, aber ich glaube, die deutsche Sprache ist ja deutlich älter. Ich glaube, die kannst du schon auch deutlich besser alt wirken lassen. Irgendwie sind englische Dialekte nicht so albern. Da akzeptierst du, dass das harte Volk von der Küste, das sind halt Schotten oder Iren, und die feinen Herren, die Adligen sind englisch. Und das akzeptierst du, wohingegen den Deutschen, jetzt das Küstenvolk Hamburgerisch sprechen würde, würdest du denken, das ist albern. Das kommt nicht cool rüber. Aber ein guter Thread bei Twitter neulich von Maria Lorenz, glaube ich, die Podcaster-Kollegin, wann man bei englischen Dialogbüchern im Deutschen dann aufs Du geht, anstatt aufs Sie. Ja, das ist eine Frage. Fand ich eine sehr, sehr gute Frage, weil diese Regeln gibt es ja nicht, die muss es ja dann irgendwo geben, da gibt es dann so Regelbücher offensichtlich, hat dann jemand geantwortet, eine Dialogbuchautorin, die dann, da gibt es dann so Regeln, nach dem ersten Kuss zum Beispiel. Was ich sehr spät, aber sehr spät finde. Es wird in der Regel oft schnell geküsst in Filmen, da wird dann nicht noch irgendwie drei Dates ausgespielt oder so. Ja, es gibt schon auch langweilige Filme. Ja, das ist ein anderes Thema. Der Filmtipp von mir, Knives Out. Über den Anschauern, ich bin eh großer Rian Johnson-Fan, das brauche ich nicht mehr hinterm Berg halten, wissen schon eine Menge Leute. Und jetzt neuer Film, Knives Out, hat mir sehr gut gefallen. Viel Spaß dabei. Ich habe diese Woche endlich Parasite gesehen, weil es jetzt auf iTunes ist. iTunes US ist jetzt Parasite, das heißt, falls ihr zu den wenigen Leuten gehört, die diesen grandiosen Film des Jahres 2019 noch nicht gesehen hat, schaut ihn euch auf jeden Fall an, fantastisch. Unglaublich, und sechs Oscars ist nominiert als koreanischer Film. Wie cool ist das denn? Ich habe ganz vergessen, dass ja nicht englischsprachige Filme auch Oscars bekommen können. Einfach so, in allen Kategorien, nicht nur mit einem Foreign Language Best Film, sondern wirklich alle in allen Kategorien. Das habe ich ganz vergessen. Da machen wir eh nochmal unser Oscar-Spezial dazu, glaube ich, Stefan. Hat da ein paar Hot Takes? Ne? Ne, das machen da jetzt eh alle. Das ist mal über Sachen, so Specials zu machen, die niemand macht vielleicht. Aber ich finde es ja interessant, dass es dieses Jahr wieder keinen Host geben wird. Wie letztes Jahr keinen Host. Man hat sich schon überlegt, macht es irgendwie eine KI oder so? Oder irgendwie so dieses iPad auf Rädern oder so? Ein Segway. Macht es das jetzt oder so? Jetzt merkt man einfach, ich glaube, so schafft sich die Menschheit ab. Irgendwie erst ist jemand, oh, Tweetskandal, ja dann halt ohne Host und dann merkt man, es geht auch ohne Host. Und irgendwann so, brauchen wir eigentlich, brauchen wir noch Leute am Licht? Nö, macht Computer, brauchen wir noch Leute in der Kamera und irgendwann ist niemand mehr. So eine KI macht das komplett alleine. Und dann die Disco-Kugel, diese Aufmerksamkeits, wie heißt das? Ich möchte meinen Spot. Anwesenheitssimulatore ein Publikum. Ich möchte meinem Programmierer danken. Mit Tränen in den Augen. Ja, wir kommen nächste Woche wieder nach Hamburg, denn da ist unsere nächste Live-Show. Stimmt, die Live-Show in Hamburg, ich freue mich. Ich freue mich sehr drauf, ich bin sehr gespannt. Vielleicht gibt es dann auch wieder eine neue Ausgabe unserer tollen Rubrik Antenne Afrika, wo ich mich nicht darauf freue, mal live, finde ich auch nicht so schlecht.
Freut uns natürlich auch auf alle, die wir dort treffen werden in Hamburg.
Kommt vorbei, schaut vorbei.
Falls ihr Tickets noch abzugeben habt oder auf letzten Drücke noch einen braucht.
Vergesst nicht den Hashtag Puffo Live!
Immer Hashtag Puffo Live im Auge haben, da werden Tickets noch abgegeben.
Und wie gesagt, wenn ihr sie abgeben wollt, dann einfach Hashtag Puffo Live dazu, dann finden die Leute euch auch und dann kriegt ihr die los.
Und ansonsten bis dahin, macht's gut, wir sehen uns in Hamburg, haut rein, bis dahin geben wir ab.
Macht's gut, ciao!